construire un véhicule à deux roues ou
robotisée c'est le défi de ses cinq
petits ingénieurs en herbe ils
participent à un atelier consacré à la
robotique à l'espace yves montand de
guyancourt découpage assemblage soudure
ils ont pu découvrir les différentes
étapes de construction
j'ai appris à faire de la soudure a
travaillé que les engrenages ce que
j'avais jamais fait encore il ya faire
des des conduits d'électricité c'est la
première fois que j'essaie de la soudure
et est aussi un robot j'ai appris ce que
c'était un robot a aussi à différencier
des robots à d'autres au moi j'aime bien
suis vraiment d'emploi et construire
j'aime beaucoup construire soit
animatrice de l'association planète
sciences clémence encadrent cet atelier
en détaillant le vocabulaire technique
de la mécanique et de l'électricité et
en les accompagnant dans le montage de
vie et après tu révises l'association
planète sciences rempli plusieurs
objectifs à travers ses activités
ludiques et pédagogiques et sensibiliser
déjà à la robotique au robot parce que
c'est que ça fait de plus en plus partie
de notre environnement de dans notre
société tout simplement est aussi ça
leur permet pas de s'éveiller aussi à
manipuler expérimentés comment
construire vraiment un véhicule un
nouvel atelier pourrait être organisée
autour des capteurs et des logiciels
pour concevoir un véritable robot